based on the winston groom novel of the
same name forrest gump quickly cemented
itself as a cinematic classic
in fact 43 of people agree it's tom
hanks best movie
of all time high praise considering it's
company
it's got everything an unforgettable
film should have
and it's got the oscars to prove it a
fitting score masterful direction
performances for the ages and of course
pitch perfect writing to hold it all
together screenwriter eric roth may not
have known it in 1994 but forrest gump
was
destined to become one of the most
quotable movies of
all time my mom always said
life was like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're gonna get
life
may be like a box of chocolates and
stupid definitely
is as stupid does but the quote that
stands above them all has to be young
jenny's plea to a young forest with rock
wielding bullies in hot pursuit
run forest run though she makes two
similar pleas before that moment and one
after there's something about this third
iteration that sticks out
maybe it's the camera focusing in on
little jenny's face maybe it's the
tension of the bullies riding after
forest on their bikes or maybe it's just
plain nostalgia
whatever it is actress hannah r hall's
delivery of those three little words
is permanently ingrained in our
collective consciousness
luckily hall is far from a one-hit
wonder even if she now looks different
from that girl on the school bus in
greenville alabama
here's what the actress who played young
jenny and forced gump looks like today
and what she's been doing since the
movie swept the globe in the mid 90s
not even a year after forrest gump was
released hall was already onto her next
acting job with the 1995
film adaptation of goldilocks and the
three bears in which she played goldie
two 1996 television films were next up
on hall's docket
the drama film homecoming based on
cynthia voigt's novel which centers
around the four tillerman children who
must learn to survive after their mother
abandons them
and her desperate choice about a woman
named jody who escapes to an underground
world with her daughter following a
court case against her abusive
ex-husband
it wasn't until she was a bit older that
hall secured her next major role in
sofia coppola's directional debut
the virgin suicides in the 1999 drama
hall starred as cecilia lisbon
the youngest of the five lisbon sisters
hall
actually auditioned for the role of lux
lisbon played by kirsten dunst in the
film but at only 15 years old producers
felt she was too young for the more
mature character
following her turn in the virgin
suicides hall attended the vancouver
film school and appeared on camera only
sporadically
showing up as amy goodro in the 2001 tv
movie amy and isabelle
and in a string of short films released
in the early 2000s
then hall made another splash in
hollywood when she starred as
judith myers the sister of michael myers
and laurie strode in rob zombie's 2007
remake of halloween
the ensuing years found hall peppering
her resume with roles and projects like
text
the indie flick american cow slip the
adam sherman drama happiness runs
the philip k dick film adaptation radio
free album
scalene visible scars and a handful of
short films
most recently on the movie side of
things hall played melissa in dying for
the crown
she's popped up on television as well
securing guest roles on criminal minds
masters of sex and the purge amid all
this
hall found herself behind the camera
more often than she did in front of it
she worked as an assistant camerawoman
and an assistant director and
even began directing underground theater
productions in california
paul has fond memories of her days as
jenny but they're just that
memories her alabama twang is long gone
and she prefers not to try and muster it
from within
she's content with the life she made for
herself going to school and bolstering
her enviable list of talents
fans can also keep up with hall on
twitter though she doesn't tweet very
often
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you